enter Kevin O'Leary I've been a big fan
of Mr Leary's over many years he doesn't
know me with Adam but I followed his
career with Intrigue because Kevin was
very very close to maybe being a prime
minister in Canada I mean the
conservative party leader they had won
he would be by extension the leader of
the party and the leader of the country
I guess it was something to do with
Quebec and things not looking promising
there bottom line Mr Wonderful decided
to do other things that was six years or
so ago and he joins us right now Kevin
very good to have you
thank you very much I appreciate it let
me ask you about that part of your like
very few people know about it this
country of course you're well known
Canada as a result you stepped down a
lot of people were pushing you to run to
you know take over the conserved party
leadership you know it's a parliamentary
system uh but you looked at Quebec
explain why that was important and why
that maybe change your trajectory
you've got to think of Quebec as the
Florida of Canada it determines the CEO
in the case the Canadian parliamentary
system is the prime minister and so
depending on the ebb and flow of the
other provinces you really need to win
at least 23 seats in Quebec if you're
going to run a majority mandate and my
whole premise of in that race in 2016
was look give me this job for four years
let me apply what I believe are good
executional skills and I'll turn this
country around the same kind of message
that was occurring with Trump at the
time and it was a populist message
because Canada is the richest country on
Earth run by idiots and I hate to say
that as a Canadian because I have a
passport right but I'm also Irish and
I'm also emirati but I'm really unhappy
about the way Canada's run and I'm not
picking at any one politicians very weak
skill sets in management there and
that's the premise by which you want
someone from business to run a country
um you you've been very publicated
you're just saying for the Prime
Minister now prime minister Trudeau that
he's doing a horrible job that he's
making things worse you still subscribe
to that I guess right
he is one of the most successful
politicians in history he's been in that
seat forever he has zero executional
skills he is a horrible manager he
perhaps is the worst manager Canada's
ever been under the absolute worst it
can't get worse absolutely a negative
10.
um so how do you feel about Trudeau all
right oh you just answered that
let me ask you though I mean you were
being doubted I'm you're highly
in this country as well there successful
businessman uh it's a great story uh but
I've often told people in studying a lot
of business types who get woo to run for
high office be it in Canada or the
United States that um it's not as easy
and making in the political world uh is
is just not as easy as well uh that's
what made Donald Trump's Victory back in
2016 so remarkable it was so unusual uh
now that the fact that they're touting a
Jamie dimon to run
um what do you make of that
you know what you want to find and this
is I think very interesting given the
race the way it's shaping up Stateside
is can you find someone with legislative
skills that are proven in other words
has executed at a government level and
also has great executional skills in
business and there is somebody
remarkably and you mentioned it earlier
Doug burgum in North Dakota you got to
remember he I came up with him in the
software industry he created a massive
software business that Microsoft bought
but he's also been very successful as
governor of North Dakota and I know that
because I invest in North Dakota so I've
met him and I've talked to him he's the
kind of you know skill set on both sides
of the equation now I don't think he's
well known yet but when people start
saying wait a second this guy's a
legislator and he's got executional
skills in business maybe that's the kind
of person that would really work well in
government versus taking somebody right
out of business and saying go figure out
how legislation works because that is
also a tricky game but in bergam you got
both so maybe he's going to be an
interesting candidate you know I
remember when Leon Coco has been doubted
what run for president he was very
popular with the turnaround at Chrysler
and I can remember talking to him uh
sometime after that saying well why
didn't you pull the lever and run some
of the polls look very good for you he
said well it I I wouldn't be a good
politician and and with politics there's
a lot of Wheeling and dealing you can't
just make an order you can't just do
what you can as the chief executive uh
and it's just not going to work what do
you think of that that a lot of these
Wall Street business types discover what
what might work for them in business
necessarily doesn't translate to
politics
I don't agree with that I think business
is politics every day you're always
trying to solve problems negotiations
Donald Trump do they not make Headway
well you know the point is Trump had
both skills great orator great
communicator and had some experience in
business no question about that and I
would say when you go into the
presidential politics and for me as an
investor and at the end of the day we're
all investors in America because we take
our money we put it into savings and we
want the economy to work what matters
more than just the leadership role and
the orator role and who's the president
is what's the policy and at the end of
the day I invest in policy so I'm
looking for leadership that's going to
give me a package of policy and under
the Trump leadership he was very
controversial there's no question about
it but look at the policy for small
business where I operate which is 68 of
the economy that policy less regulation
more pro-business lower taxes that's the
kind of stuff that makes an economy grow
and you're seeing that benefit right now
I'm not so sure that it won't be policy
that determines the next president
regardless of the party I want to see
some policy packages and I'm looking
forward to the debates so bring on the
bergams of the world let's hear what
they got
um you know the track record as I said
is is a little sketchy uh but what's
remarkable is the success of our most
well-known would say Rich presidents uh
John F Kennedy he got Franklin Roosevelt
they were among the richest we've ever
had of course Democrats and they appeal
to the common man which seems ironic but
it but it clearly worked so Democrats
have had more success with Rich guys or
those representing our wealthiest
families making it to the highest office
in the land what do you make of that
you just described the American dream
why did I move my business out of Highly
taxed Ontario to Cambridge Massachusetts
because it's America it's where you go
if you're an entrepreneur why does
everybody want to move here from around
the world because that dream can come
true I came from nothing I was a middle
class family America gave me that
opportunity to grow a business and turn
it into multi-billion dollars in
transactions that's the American dream
why wouldn't you want that emulated by
your president yes I want a successful
entrepreneur as president man or woman
show us the way we all want to do that
that has been the American dream ever
since I was born it'll be the same in a
hundred years that's what makes this
country great that's why I do my
business here sure it's got problems but
you want the leader to actually be the
essence of the American dream to embed
that in the culture and keep a straight
narrow that's why it's the greatest
economy on Earth my God Kevin how bad
were things in in Canada you went to of
all places it Cambridge Massachusetts to
find your economic Nirvana
I'm not in Texas anymore Elizabeth
Warren kicked me out she kicked me out
and I moved to Florida where every
entrepreneur is embraced and Texas
that's why I invest now I love the
competition of States I like the fact
that 3 000 license plates a month move
to Florida out of New York everybody's
leaving Massachusetts because they can
after the pandemic California they're
not even doing business go to places
like Oklahoma West Virginia North Dakota
that's where the action is because
they're pro-business all right it would
have been an interesting prime minister
that would have been fun to watch so
we'll watch closely Uh Kevin I could fix
that place I could fix that place I know
how to do it I have no doubt then you
got a great sense of humor as well Kevin
O'Leary O'Leary vintage Shark Tank
investor so much more he did okay not
becoming prime minister there